You might have plants at your home.
Plants can be inside the house or outside.
And they can be large, like a tree or small like a rose.
Some plants are very pretty and have lots of color in their leaves and flowers.
A plant that has red or purple can be used to make paint or dye.
Plants give us many things.
Most people feel good looking at flowers and people often give flowers as presents.
Many plants like roses smell so good that they're used in perfume.
Others are used in medicine.
Some plants give us food like carrot or apple and banana trees.
Many animals also eat plants.
Can you think of an animal that eats bananas?
Trees give us shade that keeps us cool on a hot day.
We use trees for exercise when we climb them to play.